wir sind zurück und wir kommen jetzt
direkt zu der These von christian
Schubert einem der ersten
corona-kritiker der schon
corona-maßnahmen Kritiker war als es
nicht omvog und nicht salonfähig war
sie sind dran mit ihrer Teesorte
meine These ist hat mein komplizit
ich bin völlig überwältigt also meine
These ist letzten Endes das ich kann
mich immer wiederholen und das habe ich
jetzt drei Jahre lang gemacht und werde
wahrscheinlich noch die nächsten drei
vier fünf Jahre machen weil ich glaube
jetzt geht's erst richtig los jetzt geht
die Aufarbeitung los und die
Aufarbeitung wird mit Sicherheit nicht
so sein dass man sagt das war es jetzt
wir haben Fehler gemacht und jetzt gehen
wir weiter und machen so weiter wie
immer war sondern jetzt wird abgerechnet
und Abrechnung heißt für mich nicht nur
das Gerichte sprechen müssen und dass da
jetzt irgendwann mal auch Prozesse
laufen sondern dass wir uns auch ganz
groß und auch hier in der Sendung wird
sie noch mal deutlich ganz groß die
Frage stellen was ist denn eigentlich
Corona gewesen was was ist denn da
wirklich passiert warum ist man mit
Menschen in dieser Form umgegangen ist
warum hat man der natürlichen Immunität
keinen Raum gegeben warum war von Anfang
an das narrativ Fehler Virus du musst
Angst haben und die letzte Rettung das
ist die Impfung das ist die Technik und
das ist letzten Endes der
industriereibach also das war ja das
ganz große framing das drei Jahre lang
passiert ist und das war keine
Demokratie mehr das war keine
Meinungsfreiheit mehr sondern das war im
Endeffekt entweder du machst das oder du
machst es nicht und wenn du es nicht
machst dann kriegst du richtig Probleme
und sehr sehr viele sind damit in die
Spritze getrieben worden das ist
Missbrauch das ist Dramatisierung
dagegen habe ich mich massiv geäußert
denn damit machen wir Menschen erst
recht krank also was letzten Endes
passiert ist ist Corona ist gleich eine
skandalöse eine skandalöse Zeit sowas
habe ich mir nicht in mein Künsten
Albträumen ausmalen können sowas Medizin
Medien und Politik fähig sind wenn es
darum geht Menschen zu tyrannisieren zu
foltern und sie krank zu machen und wie
wir ja auch jetzt langsam sehen die
übersterblichkeiten steigen und steigen
und steigen offensichtlich ist da was im
Gange seitdem die Impfung implementiert
wurde ist Übersterblichkeit massiv es
wird noch auf die Sonne geschoben und es
wird noch auf ich weiß nicht
irgendwelche corona-infektionen von
Omegon geschoben wo gar nichts mehr ist
nein es ist die Impfung und das ist ja
jetzt wird es langsam richtig kritisch
also es ist ein Verbrechen an der
Menschheit aber das ist ehrlich gesagt
davor schon gewesen also was mit
Lockdown und Schulschließungen war das
ist sind auch Verbrechen gewesen nur
haben das wenige gesehen
diese Medizin hat versagt und das ist
mein Thema finden sie ist falsch das ist
doch immer geben wird ich finde es eine
Katastrophe also das muss von heute auf
morgen beendet werden hier werden
Menschen in den Schaden getrieben und
zwar bewusst die Zahlen sind alle Tisch
jetzt kommen sie mit dem Verbot Rhythmus
nee willst du da darf man sich gar nicht
mehr impfen lassen wenn sie glauben sie
schädlich oder wie soll ich das jetzt
verstehen
ich sehe den Sinn nicht darin wenn Sie
mir sagen können was der Sinn der
Impfung impfen lassen will dann gibt es
das völlig egal was sie dazu beitragen
weil sie sind einer von wenigen der so
spricht wie sie sprechen es gibt auch
Leute die sind für Impfungen durchaus
zugänglich es hat auch die Infos schaut
wieder niemand bestreiten dass die
Impfungen sehr positive Auswirkungen
gehabt haben ob sie jetzt negative noch
dazu haben und mehr als gefördert kann
ich jetzt nicht
entscheidend
ist immer die Impfung Schulter nur dass
man jetzt genau
nicht alles vorschreiben ist aber
vorschreiben wenn das nicht nicht impfen
lassen darf ich war immer schon dagegen
dass es einen Impfzentrum gibt ja aber
immer dafür dass man sich impfen lassen
wie immer dass man sich jetzt doch Zwang
zwängen lassen muss dass man nicht mehr
geimpft werden darf das heute für ein
bisschen Freiheit für alle Entscheidung
egal ab einem bestimmten Alter will ich
auch kein Thema darin sehen machen Sie
was Sie möchten und wenn Sie meinen dass
sie sich da impfen lassen und meinen
dass ihnen nicht Angst und Panik
eingejagt wurde von Beginn an
zum Panik naja es ist nun mal eine
ziemlich kritische Geschichte von was
haben und ich weiß dass sie sich jetzt
wehren kann ich mir gut vorstellen ich
würde mich auch werden vor der Wahrheit
weil wenn solche Schäden jetzt da sind
die Inbegriff der Wahrheit den haben sie
sie allein das ist wirklich interessant
an Mediziner oder oder oder Menschen aus
dem medizinischen Fach für sich die
Wahrheit beanspruchen dort immer Angst
der Unterschied zwischen uns beiden
studiert habe ich bin Medizin
studiert ja das ist richtig aber wir
können gerne über die Erkenntnis
theoretischen Irrtümer der Schulmedizin
unterhalten und da kann ich Ihnen gleich
sagen da haben ein riesen Problem ja sie
haben aber wir haben gerade eigentlich
ein Konsens Punkt ohne dass sie beide es
merken und zwar hast du gerade gesagt
kannst das wird die immer Angst und
Bange wenn Mediziner die Wahrheit so
gesehen für sich eine Anspruch aber
genau das ist doch in der
corona-pandemie passiert oder also es
war doch genau das was nur noch
Mediziner und Virologen geredet haben
wenige wurden gehört nicht mehr alle ist
nicht genau das passiert in der Zeit in
ein Ausmaß in einem geringen Ausmaß Jahr
geringen stärkeren Ausmaß aber trotzdem
ich meine wir haben ja auch einiges
verhindert durch diese Interaktionen sie
machen das ständig da wieder Deutschland
der Unrechtsstaat ist ob der ganzen Welt
ist das passiert
Entschuldigung
ist nicht ein Unrechtsstaat deswegen
weil sie finden oder Österreich und
ulrichstadt deswegen weil sie finden ist
habe ich jetzt gesagt Deutschland
Österreich
übrigens unter anderem bei der
Bundeswehr ist ja nicht abgeschafft also
Menschen können ja immer noch nicht
komplett frei entscheiden ob sie sich
impfen lassen oder nicht in manchen
Bereichen es gibt auch es gibt auch
Institute für Psychotherapie wo man das
auch immer noch machen muss Fehler du
warst Regierungssprecher von Gerhard
Schröder die Frage die ich mir stelle
ist jetzt gerade wenn du jetzt Regierung
Sprecher wärst wie würdest du denn
eigentlich agieren und was würdest Du
raten zur Aufarbeitung weil das was
aufgearbeitet werden muss das sieht ja
fast jeder Bürger so absolut als
Regierungssprecher gibst du ja auch
immer die die Linie der Regierung wieder
deswegen ist sie halt die Frage wie frei
ich wäre jetzt hier in meiner eigene
Meinung da reinzugeben aber was doch
völlig klar ist aus diesen beiden sehr
prägnanten Statement ist dass wir
Aufklärung brauchen und als Regierung
sprechen würde ich diese Aufklärung auch
vorantreiben weil es kann natürlich sein
dass der Schubert Recht hat es kann auch
sein dass sonst mal recht hat ich weiß
es nicht ich war ausgesetzt den ganzen
Prophezeiungen von den verstärkten von
den Drosten der sagte dreimal infiziert
dreimal möglichst schwer und dann
dreimal geimpft und dann ist man
vielleicht durch was Corona angeht bzw
geschützt das fand ich schon so aber
wenn man das gesagt hat war das
natürlich auch nicht richtig ich war
auch zeitweise auch richtig für eine
Impfpflicht ich habe da hier schon oft
mehr akulpa gesagt habe gesagt das war
falsch aber das habe ich auch im
Nachhinein erst immer offen gegenüber
anderen Meinungen offen war ich auch
aber hier noch mal konkret zu deiner
Frage hier brauchen wir Aufklärung ich
habe auch mal finde auch wir brauchen
eine Untersuchungsausschuss der das auch
mal erklärt was war denn da was lag den
vor welche Erkenntnisse gab es ähm warum
hat man wieder agiert und vor allen
Dingen wie ist es heute ähm jetzt bin
ich auch alarmiert wenn ich jetzt höre
von einem verdienten Mediziner der mir
sagt das nutzt alles nichts denke ich
was habe ich denn da drin ne ähm gibt
das vollgeschehen oder was
und und das müssen wir aufklären
wirklich weil so geht es doch ganz
vielen Menschen die sich immer mehr die
Frage stellen war das denn wirklich
alles okay Wolfgang Kubicki hat ja etwas
vorgeschlagen er hat ja vorgeschlagen
dass wir Obduktion von kürzlich
verstorbenen Corona geimpften vornehmen
ja alles was halten Sie von dem
Vorschlag von Wolfgang
also die Aufarbeitung fehlt ja nicht nur
in Sachen Impfung was mich mich haben
zwei Dinge gestört von Anfang an sind
die wirklich gravierenden
Kollateralschäden auch für die
Gesundheit der Leute nicht beachtet
worden das haben Leute keinen Sport mehr
treiben dürfen sind verfettet sind
andere haben psychische Störungen
bekommen weil sie ihren eingesperrt
waren im Lockdown Schulen wurden
geschlossen Kinder wurden traumatisiert
ich bin kein Psychologe aber ich kann
mir das lebhaft das sind nur die
kurzfristigen nur die kurzfristigen also
dass die Kollateralschäden überhaupt
nicht in Rechnung gezogen wurden das ist
einfach eine hieß du darfst an allem
sterben nur nicht an Corona ja das ist
die Umdrehung der Mensch ist doch nicht
für ein Gesundheitssystem da sondern das
Gesundheitssystem ist für die Menschen
da und das alles abhängig zu machen von
den freien Plätzen Intensivstationen das
ist völliger Irrsinn und das zweite ist
das ist langfristige hochbedingtlich
der Wissenschaft wurde großer Schaden
zugefügt denn es wurde behauptet es gibt
die Wahrheit Herr drostens die Wahrheit
die anderen wie er sind die Unwahrheit
das Wissenschaft immer bedeutet Skepsis
ja das ist sozusagen das
eigentümliche von Wissenschaft überhaupt
dass man skeptisch ist dass man Trial
and Error dass man was behauptet das
widerlegt dass man mit den Dingen
arbeitet aber stattdessen wurde bei uns
das zu einer Wahrheit aufgezogen das was
bestimmte Wissenschaftler die sich von
der Regierung haben missbrauchen lassen
würde ich sagen die wurden hoch gehypt
und die anderen wurden auch mit ziemlich
interessanten Mitteln da könnten sie
wahrscheinlich einiges erzählen
geschafft die verloren ihre
Forschungsgelder die verloren zum Teil
ihre Jobs ja das darf man nicht
vergessen und das muss aufgearbeitet und
das ganze hat wie gesagt eine
Entwicklung und am Anfang war ich auch
skeptisch ja und da habe ich Skepsis
geäußert und habe gesagt Mensch schaut
euch das doch mal an da läuft doch was
schief ja
und jetzt sage ich Ihnen jetzt sage ich
Ihnen genauso knallhart wie davor die
anderen geredet haben dass das falsch
war und deswegen finde ich es super gut
die Diplomatie jetzt gelten zu machen
und zu sagen wir setzen uns zusammen
lassen uns das jetzt wirklich mal in
Ruhe bereden und lass mal jede Stimme
gelten bin ich völlig dabei finde ich
völlig in Ordnung aber ich werde jetzt
laut sein und ich werde weiterhin laut
bleiben ja und ich lass mir das mit
Sicherheit nicht verbieten ich habe das
vor drei Jahren nicht verbieten lassen
und ich werde mir jetzt nicht verbieten
lassen schon gar nicht hier jemand ganz
sicher
ich bin nur immer sehr skeptisch das
wiederhole ich deswegen bin ich nicht
sozusagen die Anti-These dr Schubert ich
möchte nur nicht eine absolute Wahrheit
haben wenn es keine absolute Wahrheit
gibt ja vielleicht oder in manchenrecht
vielleicht auch nicht ja also es kann
man hier nicht beantworten
die Wahrheit liegt irgendwo wo man sich
vielleicht nachweisen kann deswegen ja
Untersuchungsausschuss wird alles lange
dauert und das Wichtigste ist dass wir
nur am das nächste vom ehrlich
gesprochen worden ist die Kinder die
eindeutig wissen und das ist das
furchtbarste der ganzen Geschichte weil
das hätte man tatsächlich verhindern
können über die Wirkung der Impfung kann
man streiten von mir aus ja aber das wir
Schulen geschlossen haben und die Kinder
sozusagen ausgesperrt haben die zu Hause
zu Hausarrest verpflichtet haben das ist
natürlich furchtbar gewesen das war
Unsinn und das müssen wir heute zusehen
und ich würde gerne noch was dazu sagen
weil ich bin ja ich möchte nicht so
gelten als jetzt der docmatiker der da
jetzt darüber wischt ich kann das auch
gut verstehen dass man sich jetzt Wert
gegen diese sogenannte Wahrheit und ich
sag das auch immer wieder in meinen
Interviews Vorsicht jetzt ja Vorsicht
die Impfung jetzt als das grausame
Mordinstrument hinzustellen ja das tun
ja so manche meiner Kollegen auch auf
meiner Seite ja und damit schaffen wir
im Endeffekt auch nur Angst und schaffen
im Endeffekt nur wenn es das Gegenteil
von Placebo ist Nordsee oder das heißt
wir setzen Effekte wo die Menschen Angst
bekommen und dann erst recht krank
werden obwohl die Impfung vielleicht
nichts getan hat und gar nicht so
stofflich gefährlich ist aber es ist
eben mehr die Impfung ist nicht nur
Aufarbeitung die eine saubere
Aufforderung die Impfung ist wie gesagt
nicht nur biologisch ist nicht nur ein
Stoff dass ich ihn eine messenger-rna
sondern es ist eben alles drumherum auch
es ist biopsychosozial aufgeladen es ist
ein Symbol geworden und ich möchte das
Symbol nicht bedienen und andere in
Angst und Schrecken versetzen mit dieser
Impfung das ist letzten Endes nicht das
was ich möchte das insofern tut mir dann
auch leid weil darum geht's nicht dass
das dass wir jetzt sozusagen die andere
Seite plötzlich laut wird und zu laut
wird und zu bedrohlich und bösartig aber
wir haben viel einstecken müssen die
letzten drei Jahre und deswegen
wird man da auch emotional würden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie